le soleil n'est pas encore levé que
louis bilodeau se dirige vers la
bergerie sa bergerie
au début les échos chaud j'ai mal à mon
poids je voulais pas parce qu'elle
n'avait pas vraiment emplacement et
trois jours temps j'ai proposé d'élever
mon temps je m'étais dit que vous en
grêce belhout au nom de leurs pulls mélo
lui il voulait d'orwell l'année louis
n'avait que 12 ans lorsqu'il a acheté
son premier troupeau pour 6000 dollars
de l'argent de poche amassés au fil des
ans en vendant du maïs cultivé sur la
ferme de ses parents
l'adolescent partage aujourd'hui son
temps entre l'école secondaire et
l'élevage de moutons 14 ans il est à la
fête de troupeaux 220 qu'est ce qui va
se passer quand j'ai besoin de falla et
36 j'aime ça parce que je trouve ce
cocasse année qu'est ce que j'ai à moi
c'est l'épée du jeu c'est quelqu'un qui
fait saliver et par salvatore me sens un
peu mal n'envoyer patrouille s'est
essayé à l'it et le plus extraordinaire
c'est que louis van la totalité de sa
production à une amie de sa mère
frédéric morin du restaurant joe beef à
montréal l'une des meilleures tables de
la métropole
c'est vraiment un agneau de distinction
l'allemagne ont un peu plus persillé qui
est plus proche des agneaux américains
qui sont pas mauvais du tout c'est
vraiment fantastique
j'ai quand même surpris il ya beaucoup
de monde ce marché baissier avant
d'élever même temps jamais mangé la
viande longtemps je manger du boeuf
puisque parmi les viandes plus quand
même où on sera le jeune entrepreneur
dans dix ans il y à fort à parier qu'il
aura persévérer et que son entreprise
aura pris de l'expansion
il a déjà fait sa place au sein de la
communauté des élevages sérieusement la
cua pas moins vrai dans une croix pimp
rannochia ici julie vaillancourt radio
canada montréal